[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de france 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y en este
programa intentaremos hacer una
radiografía de lo que han sido cuatro
años de gobierno de andrés manuel lópez
obrador en mexico
recientemente el mandatario presentó su
cuarto informe de gestión en un tono
optimista y mostrando cifras de mejora
sobre ellas y sobre su contexto las
conversaciones era con carol arriaga
secretaria nacionales de morena mujeres
y también con héctor saúl tello diputado
federal del pan por la ciudad de méxico
y secretario además de la comisión de
presupuesto y cuenta pública de la
cámara de diputados a ambos gracias por
estar con nosotros y a nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
hacen parte de esta conversación dejen
sus preguntas y comentarios en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter
instagram y facebook en donde nos
encuentran con arrobo france24 guión
bajo el s y ángel ago efe 24 mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 en youtube pueden seguir
nuestra señal en streaming y también
saludamos a las personas que nos
escuchan en nuestro post no olviden que
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
están disponibles en apoyo podcast
spotify deezer y tune in así las cosas
vamos a comenzar y para abrir el debate
escuchemos primero las declaraciones de
ambos sobre datos de homicidios a la
baja
y mucha gente no sepa o tenga una
percepción
distinta por la campaña
sensacionalista amarillista
de los medios de información que actúan
al servicio de nuestros adversarios
conservadores
pero con datos del inegi
podemos demostrar que hemos reducido el
número de homicidios en 2.82 por ciento
ahí estaban las declaraciones de ambos
en este cuarto informe de gestión y en
medio de su gobierno que ha calificado
con la cuarta transformación mexicana y
comienzo con carol arriaga seguridad de
robos secuestros y otros delitos en
general el cargo le se redujeron 23,4
por ciento dice amlo y aunque las cifras
son mejores se dice también que son
medios amarillistas los que desinforman
en su contra usted qué opina
en efecto estamos ante una oleada de
amarillismo de sensacionalismo de pronto
hemos pasado de la sociedad del
espectáculo a la sociedad del ridículo y
creo que eso no ayuda a
analizar objetivamente por el bien de
méxico pues las necesidades en seguridad
de nuestro país sin duda el presidente
de la república ha hecho esfuerzos
sobrehumanos para mejorar el tema de la
seguridad y hoy tenemos que los delitos
del fuero federal han bajado en un 29.3
por ciento de igual forma en
coordinación con los gobiernos estatales
y municipales se ha logrado disminuir el
robo de vehículos en 43 puntos uno por
ciento y el secuestro ha disminuido en
un 81 por ciento y se ha reducido
también el número de homicidios en 2.82
por ciento y en lo que va del año se
estima que este ha descendido un 10.4
por ciento entonces sin duda es muy
importante estos datos se creó también
la guarda la guardia nacional y para
ello se construyeron 242
cuarteles de los casi 500 que se tienen
previstos
que estén en funcionamiento a final de
esta sección de este sexenio y se han
reclutado y formado profesionalmente a
115.000 elementos entonces sin duda pues
son son datos
muy alentadores sabemos que el tema de
seguridad es un tema muy sensible en la
población pero también hay que entender
que este proceso
de violencia en el país pues lo venimos
los venimos heredando desde salinas de
gortari y que con felipe calderón y su
guerra contra el narcotráfico pues
creció con efectos exponenciales hoy
estamos avanzando y estamos muy
orgullosas de los logros de nuestro
presidente
bueno ese fue el mensaje de lópez
obrador que méxico está avanzando pero
desde otra mirada está héctor téllez del
diputado federal del pan héctor por
favor su opinión es sobre las cifras que
presentó el mandatario
gracias angela pues bueno es la realidad
obviamente siempre supera a la
propaganda oficialista del gobierno es
una completa mentira nosotros solamente
tenemos que salir a muchas comunidades
en nuestro país para saber que la
violencia está completamente desbordada
hay pueblos enteros tomados por el
crimen organizado la política y la
estrategia de la presidencia de llevar a
cabo esta estrategia de abrazos y una
balazo simplemente ha sido un rotundo
fracaso los números son fríos y son
crueles en este momento estamos viviendo
la ola más violenta de los últimos 20
años en nuestro país muchos se quejaban
la izquierda en aquel momento y agredían
y cuestionaban mucho el gobierno de
felipe calderón yo te quiero comentar a
ti angela y al auditorio en aquella
época durante todo el sexenio hubo
apenas un poco más allá de 60 mil
muertes violentas con enrique peña nieto
hubo más alrededor de 120.000 muertos
durante seis años pero el crecimiento
exponencial de que hablan pues
obviamente de violencia es ahora con
este gobierno en este gobierno a tan
sólo cuatro años de que andrés manuel
lópez obrador llegó al gobierno ya
tenemos más de 135 mil muertes violentas
en el país este crecimiento exponencial
es resultado de una política errónea en
atacar al crimen organizado ya la
delincuencia pero no sólo eso también ha
habido violencia contra las mujeres este
gobierno se caracteriza por ser el
gobierno más misógino y que menos apoya
a las mujeres hay
3500 feminicidios acumulados durante 4
años en en el mandato de andrés manuel
lópez obrador y eso nos da que por lo
menos 11 mujeres diariamente pues son
muertas en nuestro país por razón de
género y a esto le tenemos que sumar la
ola de violencia que ha venido
desplazando a miles de ciudadanos de sus
hogares simplemente hay que ver de
zacatecas pues donde el desplazamiento
de las familias de sus hogares es enorme
ya en el país se ha levantado una alerta
muy grave por el desplazamiento de
personas motivo de la violencia que ya
llevó a por lo menos 45 mil personas
desplazadas de sus hogares con motivo de
violencia estos números son fríos esos
números son crueles hay un gobierno que
no está atendiendo en materia de
seguridad y al presidente se le otorgó
en el año 2019 la creación de la guardia
nacional y
no recibir un segundo sino porque no
quiere escuchar su opinión sobre la
guardia nacional sino porque quisiera
que vayamos a punto por punto y este
tema le tenemos dedicado un espacio
dentro de este debate mientras tanto
héctor usted estaba mencionando el tema
de los feminicidios que usted lo ha
dicho ha sido muy sensible durante el
gobierno de lópez obrador y por eso
quisiera volver a carol arriaga carol
usted es secretaria nacional de morena
mujeres cuál es la opinión que le merece
el manejo de los feminicidios dentro del
gobierno de anv lo porque claro se
presenta un informe en el que por
ejemplo al corte de julio de agosto pues
el gobierno o saca pecho diciendo que
han disminuido los feminicidios respecto
a la misma cifra de los mismos meses en
el año anterior sin embargo no tendría
que ver también pues los históricos y
las cifras de feminicidios se van
elevando constantemente desde el año
2015 el gobierno de lópez obrador no se
salva no es la excepción en cuestión de
feminicidios y también hemos visto a las
colectivas feministas increpando
constantemente al gobierno
exigiendo que se declaré por ejemplo
emergencia por feminicidios en el país y
un manejo que algunos tachan de
populista por parte de ambos para tratar
estos crímenes de género
si hay que entender que la violencia
contra las mujeres bueno se da a partir
del sexo y efectivamente hay una deuda
histórica del gobierno mexicano del
estado mexicano
con nosotras las mujeres yo creo que en
estos momentos también se vive una
especie de
espectáculo y reitero si no es quedar
hasta del ridículo de muchos políticos y
especialmente hombres y también de
algunas mujeres hay que reconocerlo
donde utilizan la causa de las mujeres
donde utilizan el movimiento feminista
donde
que lo utilizan para golpear para un
golpeteo de corte partidista y no en
beneficio de nosotras las mujeres
efectivamente ahí hay mucha violencia yo
no sé qué tanto ha crecido de crecido la
violencia porque hay que hay que señalar
que de año con año sexenio con sexenio
se han estado modificando los
indicadores creo que sí tenemos altos
índices de violencia contra las mujeres
el machismo persiste y lo que sí nada
ayuda es que políticos hombres utilicen
esta causa
para maquillarse para decir que están
comprometidos con las mujeres que son
hasta feministas que son aliados cuando
la verdad es que la mayoría de estas
agresiones hay que reconocerlo vienen de
los hombres sin duda el estado tiene que
actuar pero también desde desde la casa
desde la educación y desde desde
esta forma en que se está abordando por
por los políticos y las políticas el
arma creo que nada y tiene toda la razón
en que la mayoría de crímenes
feminicidas pues son cometidos por
hombres pero es que el presidente
también es hombre y es residente ha
presentado desde su gobierno cifras que
dicen que el feminicidio ha bajado y con
esto que usted mismo me está diciendo no
cree que es un poco osado por parte de
ambos o del gobierno de anv lo asegurar
que ha disminuido el feminicidio que
además está incluido dentro de esta gran
cifra de homicidio que entrega el país
cuando solamente para comparar un año
frente a
muchos años por no decir décadas en los
que aumenta y más con un delito que
certificó al menos apenas en el 2020
usted lo dice es que no hay suficientes
indicadores que sean concretos y que
sean coherentes para decir que bajo que
no bajo el feminicidio y mientras tanto
hay denuncias de colectivas que dicen
que las mujeres están muriendo que son
días 11 mujeres muriendo en méxico todos
los días si
los indicadores que tiene el presidente
en relación con el año pasado pues no
hay una modificación sin embargo ha sido
o ha resultado muy difícil que las
autoridades inclusive entiendan lo que
es esta violencia de esta violencia es
una violencia muy compleja que no es
fácil de abordar y que sin duda el hecho
de que se tome a la ligera con el único
fin de golpear al presidente de lópez
obrador no no es que perjudique al
presidente lópez obrador es que eso nos
perjudica a nosotras las mujeres
entonces yo sí haría un llamado para
tomar este tema con con mayor cuidado
con una
con respeto a todas las mujeres ya todas
las familias que han sido víctimas de
violencias y especialmente de violencias
feminicidas y lo que lo que yo creo que
en estos momentos es un es un avance es
que por en la política del presidente
lópez obrador es que todo el homicidio
cometido contra una mujer de entrada se
catalogue como feminicidio y a partir de
ahí hacer el irlos descartando poco a
poco sin embargo antes era muy
complicado decir que que se había
cometido un feminicidio ahora ahora de
entrada todo todo asesinato ha cometido
una mujer que por cierto aquí quiero
corregir a héctor no son mujeres muertas
son mujeres asesinadas y asesinadas por
hombres
entonces creo que es muy correcto que
ayuda a la sensibilización y ahí a tomar
medidas al respecto para que todo
homicidio cometido contra una mujer de
entrada se cataloga como feminicido y a
partir de ministerio y a partir de ahí
ir descartando o sea creo que eso es un
avance
falta muchísimo que hacer y es muy
difícil que un hombre pueda entender
este tipo de violencias machistas el
presidente lópez obrador no es la
excepción pero resulta ridículo decir
que el pri o que él para no que
gobiernos pasados hicieron algo por las
mujeres la agenda si es que vamos a
pasar el siguiente tema quedó
perfectamente claro su punto y ahora sí
quisiera hablar de la guardia nacional
es que son muchos puntos los que habló
el presidente y los que tenemos que
debatir hoy hay protestas y rechazos
ciudadanos se han dado durante las
últimas semanas por esta idea de anv lo
que ha dicho que cambió de opinión y que
ahora quiere una reforma de la guardia
nacional para que ya no esté gestionada
de maneras civiles sino que ahora haga
parte de la sedena la secretaría de la
defensa nacional
porque mantener al ejército en las
calles y cuáles serían las consecuencias
ahora le pregunto a usted debe primero
héctor
bueno lo que nosotros estamos viendo
como te mencionaba es un momento ángel
ar pues en el año 2019 celedón se le dio
un voto de confianza al presidente de
lópez obrador pidió la creación de la
guardia nacional precisamente con el
compromiso de capacitar de certificar de
fortalecer las policías locales y
estatales para ir poco a poco de forma
progresiva
y induciendo al ejército para que
volviera a los cuarteles y ejercer su
facultad exclusiva que es la de
protección de la soberanía nacional y en
este caso crear el cuerpo de la guardia
civil que fuera fortaleciéndose para que
el mando civil se fuera concentrando de
esa forma desgraciadamente después de
dos años y medio de la creación de la
guardia nacional vemos que los
resultados han sido pues mínimos se le
entregaron presupuestos extraordinarios
e históricos te quiero comentar que en
este último año por lo menos ha tenido
más de 65 mil y millones de pesos para
la guardia nacional se lo otorgaron ya
113 mil activos es decir efectivos
guardias para la seguridad y pues bueno
los lamentables que nos damos cuenta que
de 10 activos de la guardia nacional 9
son militares qué quiere decir esto el
presidente lópez obrador nunca echó a
andar el programa de ir 10 militarizando
al país y a la guardia nacional por el
contrario se fue fortaleciendo la
presencia del ejército y hoy lo que se
pretende es llevar a cabo ya formalmente
una militarización nos acaban de
presentar una iniciativa que fue pues
aprobada en 'fast track' en la madrugada
en lo oscurito con muchas prisas
violando todos los procesos legislativos
para precisamente llevar a cabo esta
reforma que aparte es a todas luces
inconstitucional no se atrevieron a
hacer una reforma constitucional porque
no tienen los votos suficientes y se
fueron por la parte de atrás a modificar
leyes secundarias con esa mayoría simple
que le da la alianza que tienen entre
morena verde y el pp y obviamente
violentando la constitución en su
artículo 21 que es claro el mando de la
guardia civil de la guardia nacional
debe de ser de carácter civil y hoy lo
que vemos es completamente lo contrario
tenemos que hacer un poquito de memoria
en que precisamente una de las
principales propuestas del presidente de
lópez obrador era llevar a cabo la
desmilitarización en el país y hoy hace
completamente lo contrario y se
mantienen los militares en la calle sin
embargo el presidente también fue claro
al emitir esta idea diciendo que cambió
de opinión y ahora le quiero preguntar
usted carol que piensa desde morena
sobre este cambio de enfoque del
presidente
coincido en que uno es de sabios cambiar
de opinión y dos que el partido acción
nacional pues no puede quejarse de este
proceso de militarización cuando ellos
han sido quienes impulsaron pueden estar
o no de acuerdo pero lo cierto es que si
el país se militarizó puede por esta
oleada que se ha generado una crisis
exponencial de violencia y que el
presidente lópez obrador ha
contenido no iba y va creciendo a pasos
exponenciales gracias a esa política esa
guerra del narcotráfico contra el
narcotráfico que todo el mundo sabe que
hubo fallas y que además hay una clara
una clara colusión entre las autoridades
e
gubernamentales entre los gobiernos
panistas y los gobiernos priístas con
actores de crimen organizado y basta
nadamas voltear a ver
a genaro luna y hay muchos muchos otros
elementos de la policía fallida de esa
policía que desde el gobierno federal
cometía crímenes en colusión con
organizaciones criminales y hoy
afortunadamente eso cambio estamos en
una nueva era en una era donde el
presidente de lópez obrador pues está
poniendo todo su empeño para trabajar de
manera coordinada con los estados con
los municipios y ha sido una prioridad y
gracias a esos grandes a esos esfuerzos
mayúsculos pues se ha logrado prender o
contener esta oleada exponencial que
repito inició con carlos salinas de
gortari recordemos los años 80 es
el tema de caro quintero y sin duda pues
la oleada de violencia que todo el mundo
vivió durante el gobierno de felipe
calderón que fue el que inició este
proceso hoy el presidente pues tiene en
sus manos una
a titanic a una tarea muy difícil que es
muy sensible para toda la sociedad
mexicana y que debemos de darle no
solamente el voto de confianza sino en
apoyar en apoyar en qué sentido bueno
creo que la apuesta a largo plazo es
justamente la recomposición del tejido
social que gracias a las políticas
neoliberales pues
se vio muy afectado y hoy estamos en una
en una era diferente los frutos también
hay que reconocer no son inmediatos es
como cuando siempre hace un árbol
primero está la semillita y después
crece qué es una planta y después se
convierte en un árbol no son inmediatos
no hay varitas mágicas pero los
esfuerzos están ahí están presentes y
afortunadamente como ya lo anuncié hace
un momento pues los delitos en el foro
federal han bajado en un 29 3 puntos por
ciento no son son datos ciber de duros
son son cifras reales
y sin duda falta mucho por hacer pero
los mayores frutos se van a ver en unos
pocos años y si tenemos que pensar a
futuro y no solamente en un sexenio para
que esto para que para para tener un
proyecto realmente por méxico sea
queremos que este proyecto de nación
continúe y ahí a ese y en ese camino y
así ese camino vamos bien y a pesar del
amplio despliegue de la guardia nacional
y de estas cifras duras que usted
menciona carol y con los militares
presentes en diferentes estados del país
persisten los niveles de inseguridad de
méxico persisten las masacres persisten
por ejemplo los crímenes a periodistas
que también es una cifra fuerte que ha
tocado este año los noticieros
nacionales e internacionales ya son 16
periodistas asesinados hasta la fecha y
no hemos terminado todavía el año como
evaluar esta estratégica de poner a los
militares en las calles y de aumentar
esta fuerza militar al cambiar de
dependencia la guardia nacional como se
evalúa esta estrategia a la luz pues de
estos resultados que usted menciona y
que sin embargo no se conduelen con
realidad que se vive en las calles
mexicanas
y de los asesinatos a los periodistas no
no son un tema de este sexenio repito
esto fue creación de estos gobiernos
neoliberales de esta corrupción entre
organizaciones criminales y entre el
gobierno y lo cierto es que en estos
momentos no son no es desde el gobierno
federal que se mandan a asesinar a los
periodistas como en otro sexenio se se
hacían
sin duda reiteró tenemos una crisis de
seguridad pero esta crisis de seguridad
de hay que entender que es un fenómeno
que heredó y que potenció principalmente
felipe calderón y que estamos en un
proceso de recomposición que tarda
tiempo que no es un tema de la
inseguridad se acaba por decreto
presidencial sino en eso se tiene que
trabajar es una apuesta a mediano a
largo plazo y los esfuerzos están
haciendo justamente el tema de detener
y militares dada la formación que se
tiene dada la historia de estas
agrupaciones que son las más antiguas en
el gobierno pues da da mayores elementos
para tener
personas especializadas en la materia
con mayor capacitación no tenemos una
policía federal corrompida eso es una
realidad y acabar con estas estructuras
reitero no no no es por arte de magia
hay que entender que esto es un proceso
que ya se inició el cambio y que están
por darse los frutos de injerto es que
la
violencia pues no ha no ha crecido o sea
se ha detenido en tanto
el gobierno de felipe calderón reiteró
creó un
contexto de suma violencia de
una agresión militar cotidiana y hoy
esto ya no es así o sea hoy hoy hoy
vamos a ver entonces señalaron perdone
pero tenemos que darles igual tiempo a
los dos sectores cuál es su opinión
sobre esto tiene algo que agregar o
pasamos al siguiente tema
claro que si quisiera agregar que bueno
el discurso propagandístico de morena
siempre es el mismo y hoy carol lo
vuelve a repetir es echar la culpa al
pasado echar la culpa a los de atrás yo
creo que ya hay 4 años de gobierno en
donde se debe de asumir la
responsabilidad de las políticas
públicas que se ejercen en el país y en
este caso la política de seguridad es es
mala no hay buenos resultados yo te
quiero comentar que a pesar de todo lo
que se comenta de la policía federal
anterior por lo menos promediaba 21.000
detenciones derivadas de inteligencia
policiaca hoy es muy lamentable conocer
que para empezar la guardia nacional no
tiene un cuerpo de inteligencia es decir
no existe la guardia nacional hoy hace
labores de patrullaje exclusivamente en
las calles no hay detenciones pues que
brindan seguridad a los ciudadanos
apenas han llegado en toda su historia a
la guardia nacional a 8.000 detenciones
derivadas de la guardia nacional eso
contrasta completamente con la actuación
de la policía federal antes en donde
promediaba por lo menos al año 21 mil
detenciones entonces esas son las
grandes diferencias había un proceso que
venía caminando como bien dice carol
lleva tiempo pero ya había muchos
avances en la certificación en el
fortalecimiento de las policías
estatales y municipales como en todo
pudo haber errores pero no se puede
llegar a llegar a destruir lo que bien
se estaba haciendo también tenemos que
recordarle a la ciudadanía que este
gobierno hizo la propuesta de
desaparecer el portal se que el portal
se es un fondo que existía en el
presupuesto de egresos para precisamente
fortalecer las policías locales y
estatales y municipales había alrededor
de 10 mil millones de pesos hoy no
existe ni un solo peso para llevar a
cabo esta tarea de fortalecimiento de
las policías y pues eso es lo que es lo
grave vemos una estrategia del gobierno
del un debilitamiento presupuestal de
todas las policías precisamente para
echar a andar el brazo armado es
característico de cualquier dictadura y
nos da temor
este es el camino que se está abriendo
para que el presidente tenga un brazo
armado y se pueda comenzar a ejecutar
una dictadura y el autoritarismo en
nuestro mexico bien como nuestro tiempo
es limitado vamos a pasar a un siguiente
tema y vamos a meternos más en asuntos
económicos méxico está hoy en día
todavía por debajo del nivel de
producción que tenía antes de la
pandemia el fondo monetario
internacional ha pronosticado
recientemente que el país podría crecer
un 2.4 por ciento este año aunque el
gobierno atribuye esta falta de
crecimiento a la pandemia lo cierto es
que el país azteca ya venía con algunos
problemas de crecimiento desde antes de
que comenzara esta gran e histórica
crisis sanitaria carol usted cómo ve la
perspectiva de crecimiento y sobre todo
el discurso del presidente en el sentido
de que méxico está mejorando
si te mira a mí me gustaría solamente
señalar que la iniciativa que se se está
presentando y la incluye la reforma a
cuatro leyes justamente para dotarle a
la guardia nacional labores de
investigación y de inteligencia entonces
es falso lo comentado por héctor bueno
hay que señalar que que hemos logrado
una estabilidad financiera sin aumentar
los impuestos sin subir los precios de
los combustibles o endeudar al país como
tradicionalmente se hacía el plan de
cero corrupción y de impunidad y de
erradicar los lujos en el gobierno ha
permitido contar con un ahorro de
alrededor de 2.4 billones de pesos
y a pesar de la inflación los ingresos
del gobierno federal se han incrementado
en un 2.4 por ciento con relación al año
pasado el peso no se ha devaluado y ha
estado en los tres primeros lugares
entre los países del mundo por su
fortaleza está en relación con él con el
dólar entonces sin duda son dos logros
muy importantes
que no tuvieron los gobiernos pasados en
los que se dedicaban a endeudar el país
y haber el gobierno como un negocio
héctor
bueno nosotros estamos viendo angela un
país completamente devastado en materia
económica es uno de los rubros que más
ha sido lastimado por este gobierno
estamos viviendo las tasas de inflación
más altas en los últimos 22 años hoy
estamos prácticamente en
8.67 el promedio de inflación eso hace
que los productos de la canasta básica
pues hoy se hayan disparado no
simplemente hay que preguntarle a las
personas cuánto están gastando el día de
hoy
en el mandado tradicional que hacen para
su manutención yo te quiero comentar que
antes durante el 2018 el promedio de la
canasta básica estaba en alrededor de 3
mil 89 pesos con esta inflación pues
obviamente no se puede comprar lo mismo
hoy para comprar lo mismo tendrían que
estar gastando alrededor de 3 mil 542
pesos es decir si se ha sentido el
deterioro económico
como bien lo mencionas datos del banco
mundial nos pone que nos vamos a
recuperar con esta tendencia así como
está trabajando este gobierno en materia
económica por ahí del 2032 2033 para
recuperar el ingreso per cápita de los
mexicanos y pues bueno eso habla de las
malas políticas económicas en este país
y todo comenzó hay que señalarlo
claramente angela desde las primeras
decisiones del presidente los lópez
obrador de dar un mensaje erróneo a
todas las inversiones al llevar a cabo
la cancelación del nuevo aeropuerto
internacional de méxico creo que fue un
parteaguas de ahí comenzaron la fuga de
capitales en nuestro país hoy te puedo
asegurar que la fuga de capitales ronda
más allá del billón de pesos es decir
estamos hablando de una suma que no se
había visto en fuga de capitales en
ningún otro sexenio en nuestro país y
eso habla claramente de que está
deteriorada nuestra economía apenas el
día de ayer se acaban de emitir los
bonos en cetes al 10%
en la tasa que está manejando el banco
de méxico- eso quiere decir que al
gobierno le está costando mucho trabajo
financiarse las megaobras por capricho
que está haciendo el presidente son muy
caras para la economía mexicana estamos
hablando del tren maya del aeropuerto y
de la refinería lo más lamentable de
todo ante la es que se ha llevado un
sobrecosto exorbitante en estas tres
obras por lo menos más de 500 mil
millones de pesos en sobre costo lo que
nunca se había visto al menos en la
refinería hay 200 mil millones de
sobrecoste en el tren maya habrá 200.000
millones de sobrecosto y simplemente el
aeropuerto felipe ángeles ya tuvo 40 mil
millones de sobrecosto ya todo esto
tenemos que sumarle la indemnización de
la cancelación del aeropuerto
internacional de méxico que nos va a
costar a todos los mexicanos más de 300
mil millones de pesos de así de grave
está el boquete en las finanzas públicas
de nuestro país
de su parte como ve la inversión por
ejemplo en el megaproyecto en uno de los
más sonados del gobierno y es la
construcción de este tren maya que ha
sufrido retrasos y diversas dificultades
de presupuesto como ya mencionaba su
compañero
sí yo creo que es una inversión bastante
importante y evidentemente es darle un
vuelco a toda esta forma de ver para
todos los negocios yo quiero recordar
que
del gobierno anterior pues se alejaron
por ejemplo 300 hospitales más de 300
hospitales pues prácticamente en
cascarón no y que efectivamente
ahí
un
proyecto de recuperación de
las empresas del estado que es muy
importante y creo que en este momento
apostarle a la interconexión a los temas
de telecomunicaciones al rescate del
tren al tema del aeropuerto pues sin
duda es un son proyectos muy importantes
para el bienestar de nuestro país y yo
lo celebro por ejemplo a la
recuperación de la comisión federal de
electricidad la recuperación de pemex
hay que recordar que de
de las cuatro refinerías que se tenían
pues éstas no estaban funcionando hoy ya
tenemos seis
refinerías
sin duda son bastante los logros de la
cuarta transformación en términos de
inversión pública y nos sentimos muy
honrados de este rescate que se está
haciendo a todas esas empresas y
espacios gubernamentales que tienen que
hacer de todos los mexicanos y no estar
al servicio de intereses privados y de
negocios que se han hecho al amparo del
servicio público y en los que el panismo
ha sido ha sido experto
pues el aeropuerto internacional
felipe ángeles sin duda va a ser un
gran aeropuerto y sin duda va a venir a
desarrollar mucho más nuestro país
reitero no es un proceso no se pueden
tener resultados inmediatos pero ya el
aeropuerto está eso es una es un
es una infraestructura que la podemos
ver que está funcionando que está bien
hecha es una infraestructura que se hizo
de manera ejemplar y no como los
hospitales que se dedicó a construir el
panismo y el priísmo que sobran eran
hospitales huequitos y además sin tener
personal suficiente sin apostarle a la
educación hoy la historia es otra y allí
yo les nada más diría al tiempo si
efectivamente hay una solución para no
ponerlo en marcha pero esto se va a dar
muy pronto se está construyendo
en este momento porque ya no podemos
quedarnos más en ese tema ya llegamos al
final del programa me queda exactamente
un minuto para cada uno y si les digo
menos para que me den sus conclusiones
cada uno sobre los logros o los
desatinos si es el caso del presidente
mexicano muy rápidamente héctor empiezo
con ustedes y muchas gracias bueno pues
no se debería sentir nadie orgulloso del
despilfarro y el dispendio de recursos
de manera irresponsable en nuestro país
eso pues le crea un problema grave a las
finanzas públicas y pues estamos
hablando de 500 mil millones de pesos en
caprichos de las megaobras que hoy
tienen un exorbitante sobre costo y
bueno también quedaron muchos pendientes
el presidente dijo que iba a barrer la
corrupción
con una escoba desde arriba hacia abajo
creo que esa escoba se rompió desde los
primeros días ahí están los casos de su
hermano pío lópez obrador de felip a su
prima del caso de la casa gris en
houston con baker hughes que ahora ha
tenido millones y millones de contratos
pemex de forma extraordinaria y también
tenemos que hablar de parte de ti de
toda esta este conflicto de intereses y
con toda esta inexplicable riqueza que
maneja pero son cosas que ha olvidado el
presidente al igual de señalar que hay 4
millones de nuevos pobres en nuestro
país que por desgracia se dieron durante
este gobierno entonces nada más lo tengo
completa ya nos quedamos sin tiempo y si
no claro no puede hablar caro y
rápidamente sus conclusiones
pues señalar que en el gobierno de la
cuarta transformación hasta ahora la
desigualdad se ha reducido 16 veces que
hoy existen inscritos en el seguro
social más de 21 millones de
trabajadores o sea
623.000 más antes que la pandemia que la
población indígena aumentó su ingreso
trimestral por persona de 8 mil 887 a 10
mil 57 pesos es decir hubo un incremento
del 13 punto 16 por ciento y que según
coneval en el segundo trimestre de este
año el ingreso laboral real por persona
se incrementó en 4.8 por ciento entonces
esos son logros reales y concretos y yo
espero que el panismo deje esta
demagogia que por el bien de méxico
estamos pensando en la población más
necesitada en los más pobres que
y gente como héctor no se ha visto
beneficiada pues me queda claro pero
nuestro interés no es
una mejoría a personas como estos sino
una mejoría a la mayor parte de la
población y especialmente a la gente más
necesitada bien muchas gracias a ambos
de posiciones muy alejadas pero que nos
dan un buen debate de que tendrá que
continuar fuera de las pantallas gracias
a carol arriaga secretaria nacional de
morena mujeres de ya héctor téllez el
diputado federal del pan ede por estar
con nosotros nos vemos próximamente en
el debate y en france 24
[Música]